[Music]
from Corbin to Trump populism has
rejected established political elites
something to return to ideology and
emotion is a dangerous backward step
others that this means that the
alternatives have failed
there's populism on both the left and
the right but is it something to be
celebrated or feared can giving more
power to the people
bring about positive and lasting change
or is the only safe way to make progress
to give it all to those who know best
well to discuss these subjects we have I
think the best qualified possible panel
that we could have here and that's shown
by the huge size of the audience we have
here today on the left hand side we have
John Landsman who's become very
prominent in recent years as the
national organizer for momentum the 40
thousand strong group that supports and
provides intellectual ballast for the
Corbin leadership of the Labour Party
but John has a much longer history as an
activist for a variety of causes going
all the way back to the days of Margaret
Thatcher I think not not least also not
unacquainted with Margaret Thatcher I
think is the guest on my right-hand side
the right honourable Michael Howard who
of course was leader of the Conservative
Party but also served a prior to that as
a cabinet minister in a variety of roles
including Secretary of State for the
environment and a distinguished and
experienced observer of conservative
politics also a distinguished observer
of conservative politics but perhaps one
who has
change the position of her viewing
platform is Anna super e former business
minister under the Cameron government
Conservative member of parliament for
Brock Stowe who earlier this year
switched to the new independent group
the Tigs as they're known which of
course has now taken up the party title
of change UK three people with a
tremendous amount to contribute this
afternoon would you welcome them all
here again
we'd like to hear three minutes from
each of our panelists on the key
question that we're asking is populism
both on the left and the right something
to be celebrated or something to be
feared John Landsman Thanks
well first of all I'm not quite sure
that populism really is a thing but if
it is it's more of a label it's not a
than an ideology that's for sure and I
think the important thing about it is it
represents different things very
different things
from on the right and on the left on the
right it seems to me it's very much a
blame game in which the justice
juxtaposition of the people who are good
and the elites who are bad is in which
you know it's a thing in which the
elites use scapegoats in you know that
might be Jews or Muslims or Mexicans or
perhaps even Brussels bureaucrats and
what you've really got to be aware of in
the populism of the right is the people
who are claimed to be the voice of the
people you know whether it's Trump or
Faraj I mean Trump for example and it
says that he only got lent a million
dollars by his dad but the New York
Times says that actually he benefited to
the tune of 400 million dollars from his
dad so voice of the people I'm not so
sure
on the left if if we are populist it's
it's because of the way we frame our
response to global capitalism and to the
island ideology of neoliberalism for the
many not the few which by the way is a
phrase that was not invented by Jeremy
Corbyn it was invented by
Tony Blair's advisors you'll find it in
the new Clause four of the Labour Party
Constitution is there to explain the the
work you know the differences in other
way that capitalism has changed because
one of the days when the cap of the
rather both relatively benign capitalism
of my youth was able to demonstrated
that British companies still cared about
the towns in which they of F their
workplaces took place on the workers who
work there to some extent in which bank
managers knew and understood their local
communities and economies and cared
about them and in which the state took
serious responsibility for economic
performance and well-being global
capitalism today really has no loyalty
to people or place at all global
corporations too often exist beyond the
reach of of tax authorities and
regulators government's claim you know
who claim that they believe markets will
solve everything wash their hands of
these affairs and it's not surprising
that people feel insecure on the left
however democracy really matters it
doesn't on the right where the voices of
people of the people know all people
have nothing to fear from the populism
if you want to call it that of the left
they certainly have plenty to fear from
the populism of Trump and Faraj and of
from the far right which is now growing
is a serious threat throughout Europe
and the Western world
john lunsford thank you very clear
statement there let me turn straight to
Michael Howard
well the overarching title of this
session is the will of the people and
the will of the people must prevail if
you believe in democracy there can't be
any other answer than that whether
populism and I don't think it's either a
right or a left wing thing and I think
it is a thing incidentally whether
whether populism is to be welcomed or
feared depends exactly on what you mean
by populism because it means all sort of
things all sorts of people there's a
reference in our brief maybe in what
you've read to ideology populism is
different from ideology they're not the
same things and I'll be bold enough to
offer you a definition which is that
populism is an upsurge of resentment
against an elite that is perceived often
correctly to be out of touch and out of
sympathy with the anxieties and the
concerns and the frustrations of those
people who are resentful and if that's a
if that's a reasonable definition then I
don't think it's either to be welcomed
to ought to be feared I think it's the
duty of politicians to engage with it to
recognize that it exists and to try to
engage with it and engaging with it
means addressing the concerns that have
led to that anxiety and frustration what
do I mean by addressing those concerns
sometimes you can actually meet them
sometimes you can identify the grievance
and you can actually take policy
measures which will which will
ameliorate the concerns that have led to
that grievance sometimes it's much more
difficult and it's either impossible or
actually undesirable to meet those
grievances in which case your duty I
think as a politician is to to explain
and to persuade and to persuade exactly
why it is that that grievance can't
actually be
met and explained why perhaps it's a
grievance without foundation and the
concern underlying it is misplaced and
and the policy which is being complained
about actually works to the benefit of
the people who are complaining that's
obviously not an easy thing to do but it
is part of the leadership of politicians
which is so necessary if populism is not
to boil over into the kind of anger
which feeds extremes and I take a dim
view of extremes of the right and of the
left and I think one of the reasons why
I am so keen that politicians should
engage with the concerns of populism is
in order to ensure that neither the
extremes of the right nor the extremes
of the left again a a foothold in power
of course it's not simply a concern in
this country it's not simply an issue or
a thing in this country it is something
which is apparent pretty well across the
Western world and it's only in my view
by engaging with it that leaders will
prevent the anger from boiling over and
we'll make populism a force for good as
part of the overall proposition that the
will of the people must prevail for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the institutes of arson ideas
III TV
you